movimento di spalle da tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono vari
geni se non vi ragazzi perché latina in
occasione dell'uscita del film di doctor
strange mi ha chiesto visto che ho visto
il video dove trasformare una bottiglia
in una cosa della dinosa mi ha chiesto
di fare un video dove mostro a tutti
quanti come io sto manipolare la realtà
c'è questa mano la faccia diventare
piede quindi ragazzi a distanza di un po
di man si è deciso di rifare un video
del genere dove tentò ma non solo tempo
ci riuscirò anche tenterò di manipolare
l'acqua perché io manipola le cose non
lo faccio diventare un piede quindi
ragazzo preparato un po il materiale che
useremo today che è un bel po di roba
c'è molto più di quella che gli portavo
a scuola delle matite del ghiaccio un
cucchiaio sempre migliore di quello di
italia germania vari coloranti che non
prenderò perché mi sporco tutto e ancora
ne abbiamo iniziato una bustina una
bustina non ho mai capito cosa sarà uno
stupro questa marghera il dito
principale che l'acqua e lo vado a
prendere allora questa cosa poi è un po
strana se voi prendete una bottiglietta
d'acqua e la mettete in freezer dopo 2
ore e 45 minuti che la multi diretta sa
in freezer
se le si dà un colpetto con la mano la
bottiglia diventa istantaneamente di
ghiaccio che ora il 40 cv una di fan
penso la bottiglietta in freezer disco
proveremo
di ghiaccio come trasformare la cognato
il 3 2 1 avevo detto no come trasformare
la cui viaggia il 3 2 1 togli la vedo
tutto e ora la completamente di ghiaccio
il secondo esperimento ragazzi un po più
risi c'è un pò più funzionale consiste
nel prendere una vaschetta di ghiaccio e
tu pensi nell'acqua gelata sul ghiaccio
dovrebbe crearsi del ghiaccio istantaneo
teoria non funzionerà 50 volta che fatta
salva non è così tanto per passare
dell'acqua sul ghiaccio senza che
succeda niente ragazzo meraviglioso mi
hanno venduto nell'acqua falsa bene
secondo esperimento riuscitissimo e
passiamo al prossimo
passiamo quindi ragazzi al terzo
esperimento e questo è uno dei miei
preferiti e consiste nel bere due
bicchieri un bicchiere pieno di acqua
calda e un altro bicchiere pieno di
acqua fredda esagerata sicuro ok adesso
ragazzi devo mettere del colorante su
tutti e due i bicchieri scegliere quello
rosso per l'acqua calda e con lui anche
per l'acqua fredda mito del colorante
rosso nell'acqua calda così colorante
scadente e questo problema mentre il
colorante verde ma nell'acqua fredda
questo punto il colorante veramente
brutto e ragazzi adesso abbiamo
i nostri due bicchieri quello freddo e
quello che andò ancora in teoria visto
che io altero la realtà dovrei riuscire
a posizionare il bicchiere gelido sopra
quello caldo e una volta che tolgo
questo questa cosa non dovrebbero
mischiarsi i colori in teoria il momento
della verità di bijoux pensione adesso
che ad esami di maturità ragazzi ok con
l'opposizione con una posizione aiuto
[Musica]
grazie va bene così l'invito è finito
sono riuscito a fare questa cosa va bene
adesso se io tiro questa linguetta
dovrebbe non dovrebbero mescolarsi i due
liquidi ma ma non guardare questo video
grazie per 2 1
non è una tesi e mescolate per avere uno
sporcato o non ha sporcato e non ho
sporcato va bene domanda come lo
togliamo i ragazzi siamo arrivati così
al quarto esperimento di oggi visto che
sono tutti riusciti benissimo è la
guarda alterazione della realtà oggi
useremo un sacchetto un sacchetto
dell'acqua che ho preparato qui sotto
bisogna innanzitutto versare l'acqua
fredda all'interno del sacchetto in
questo modo è una volta versata l'acqua
all'interno bisogna fare un nodo al
sacchetto e questa prima parte
inspiegabilmente alla banca è abbastanza
bene una volta fatto questo e questo lo
conoscerete tutti avanti visto almeno
una volta finita tutti quanti è
possibile far passare una patita
attraverso il sacchetto senza far cadere
l'acqua in casa questo esperimento non
riesce mia madre uscirà di testa
definitivamente perché allargano tutta
la casa quindi spero che riesca ok e le
altre nostro riusciti ma ti prego questo
si apprezzerà va bene l'acqua non esce
da ne rimangono tre però che non si
cenava 3 3 di mattina e quindi
ok ci sto chiedendo st funzionava bene
ragazzi ciao
ok e manca l'ultimo leggi e sophie la
realtà è stata alterata e quindi ragazzi
siamo riusciti ad alterare la realtà per
una volta su quattro esperimenti va già
bene sicuramente dottor strange è più
bravo di mentre l'altro il film esce il
26 ottobre io sono riuscito a fare solo
questo quindi andate a vedere lui spero
che si abbia certo io sono contento di
una gara nagato l'ala l'allegato
l'alligalli non aver allagato la casa
sono contentissimo se mi è piaciuto
ragazzi cosi lasciare un commento
e mi piace alla pagina di facebook e
come re mida parlare ad iniziare sarà
sono christie's i latini ci vediamo il
prossimo video dei ragazzi ma è da
ragazzi